talk now about a 76 year old British
Iranian businessman who's been in prison
in Iran for almost five years after
being convicted of spying kemal through
his family say they're tearing their
hair out at the lack of progress in
getting him released or even finding out
how he is he was working for an oil
company when he was arrested in 2011 and
later jailed for eight years he and this
has done nothing wrong but Iran won't
even allow UK officials to see him his
son Cameron is with me now we were
talking about this - the foreign
secretary short time ago and he says
that the British government is doing
everything possible and that's what
they're telling me as well and I keep
hearing they're doing everything they
can to help do you think they are it's
very difficult to tell at the moment you
know they've been you know lobbying hard
I know for a very long time I first made
contact with him in May 2013 and they
know how long we as a family have been
waiting very patiently and of course
seeing the US prisoners released two
half weeks ago brings you know brings
this whole case to the fore and I you
know encourage them to keep lobbying as
hard as they can and we the Foreign
Secretary also did say that he actually
should we have a quick listen to what he
said my Iranian counterpart we expect
will be in London for the Syria
conference on Thursday and I should be
speaking to him again about this issue
and we are optimistic that the Iranians
will look positively at the humanitarian
case for releasing mr. Farooqi the
Iranians do not recognize dual
nationality so they won't discuss him
with us on the basis that he is a
British national but they are looking at
these cases from a humanitarian
perspective and mr. Farooqi is an
elderly man with health issues and there
are very strong humanitarian reasons for
exercising the power of clemency that
exists in Iran and I'm very optimistic
that we will get
so he's very optimistic about progress
does that make you feel any more
comfortable well my father as well on
the morning that the u.s. prisoners were
released suddenly had a meeting with his
lawyer who was called in and his lawyer
assured him that his case was being
looked at the high priority and was very
confident to a very favorable outcome
within a week or two that was two and a
half weeks ago and I talked to my dad
again just this last Sunday and he like
thinks it might be yet another week of
course these sorts of messages bring us
hope and but as a family we have been
there before we've heard messages like
this about an imminent release and to
fade away nine times previously do do
you think well it's a very good question
and you know this is a very difficult
situation for all of us and I know the
British government has done a lot to
date and continues to do so well the
problem is he's still there I mean the
last thing we want and this could happen
any day is for him to collapse or for
very sick or die in prison you know he's
been there almost five years as you said
and we're very worried about his health
both physical and mental and this is
taking a great toll on them so it's
taking too long it is what you're saying
he's being held for spying and that's
right yes under what circumstances on
what grounds and we have no knowledge
there's no evidence to justify the
charge and he's always maintained
disease since and we were always
convinced that this was a big mistake
and and but I don't want to really sort
of affirm you know you have an
intellectual fight about the merits of
the case and I think we just want him
home that's the only thing and that's
the only reason what conditions is he
being kept in as he told you
he's not allowed to speak to us about
these sorts of things when we had three
years of being deprived of any contact
whatsoever we were extremely grateful to
get calls and we've had calls regularly
since August 2014 as one of the
conditions of those calls is that we
don't ask them he doesn't describe the
conditions
but you can pick up from his tone how
he's doing how his health is you can
pick up his the mental side of his
health and there's been a huge number of
ups and downs there are times when he
gets extremely hopeful that he's about
to be released
like like we've had in the last two or
three weeks and then in the past when
that hasn't happened he's got two
extremely down and depressed he just
wants to get out of there and get back
home to see his family picture up in
there with you is that you that is a
picture when I was young and you know my
daughter's miss their grandpa they just
want him home and we just want to you
know in-home get proper medical
treatment get fully checked out and
we'll look after him for the remaining
years of his life the challenges is that
he's got a general nationality isn't it
that is a big challenge yes III didn't
know any of this before this happened
but under the Iranian Constitution the
Iranians don't recognize foreign
citizenship and so under as a matter of
principle don't understand the you know
the you know the the case for a country
like Britain coming in and visiting him
or asking questions about why when he's
being held a British diplomats had any
contact with him as as far as I know
never why not because the Iranians
weren't allow it I think the British
have been pushing hard to try and visit
him and as far as I'm aware the Iranians
have never allowed it so when you heard
there from the Foreign Secretary saying
that he's hopeful that this should reach
a happy conclusion soon does that lift
your spirits
it does a bit it is nice to hear the
foreign secretary Singh's words and of
course you know we will never lose hope
but the reality is it probably lifts the
spirits of the nation but the reality is
until it happens not till he's back here
I won't allow myself to believe it's
really happening to me just been there
too many times in the past and to only
have our hopes dashed and we're we're
all going through this constant
oscillation between hope and despair and
I think it's just incredibly unhealthy
for the bottom and particularly my dad
but given this new spirit I hesitate to
say on touch cordial as far as Iran is
concerned but you mentioned there that
year that the American sailors were
released just a short time ago and
Arthur people that had been held by the
Iranians for some several years that
must give you hope as well that does but
it's incredible that things like the
American sailors just one phone call
between Secretary of State Kerry to
foreign minister Zarif helped solve the
issue and I just heard you were saying
that foreign minister Zarif the reigning
for Minister is coming to London on
Thursday so who knows it is possible
that he'll be bringing with him a great
to present but I'll believe it when I
see it so what would you say finally to
mr. Cameron or our foreign secretary as
far as the Iranian leader or the the
Iranian representative coming well I
want to say this as the top priority for
the British government and the British
government has lots of fire Arty's and
there's lots of talk since the nuclear
sanctions have come down about British
business going in and I can see lots of
activity there I want to see the number
one priority two is to bring my dad
grandpa Kemal home to his family
thank you very much in support we
appreciate you taking the time to talk
to us thank you